foreign
devastated Rome in response Emperor
Augustus did something that had never
been done before in the history of the
empire
he created a permanent team of
firefighters who used buckets just like
this one
Augustus understood that individuals
alone can't protect themselves from
fires
they need help from the community
when one person's house is on fire
that creates a risk for everyone else's
homes
and so what we've had these last few
years
is like a horrific Global fire the
coveted pandemic has killed millions and
upended economies and we want to stop
that from happening again
it's hard to overstate how awful it's
been
it's increased the health inequities
between the rich and the poor
survival depended partly on your income
your race uh the neighborhood you lived
in
and so we should seize this opportunity
to create a world where everyone has a
chance to live a healthy and productive
life
also a life-free
from the fear of the next covet 19. when
I was on the stage in 2015 I was one of
many people who said we weren't ready
and we needed to get ready
we didn't
the speech actually was watched by a lot
of people
but 90 percent of the views were after
it was too late
so now I hope
the need is clear
and of course we've learned a lot during
this pandemic a lot of things were well
a lot of things didn't work well and so
we have all that knowledge to build a
prevention system
covid-19 can be the last pandemic if we
take the right steps
so how what what are these steps uh well
let's go back and look at what the
Romans did uh think about how over time
we've gotten good at preventing big
fires fire prevention is kind of this
pervasive thing it's well funded it's
well understood if an alarm went off
right now everyone here would know we're
supposed to calmly gather go out and
wait instructions we know that help
would be on the way because we have lots
of trained firefighters who practice the
United States alone has 370
000 full-time firefighters even more
than uh I guessed that number would be
we also have access to water the United
States for example has almost 9 million
fire hydrants and so that type of
investment that type of practice that
type of uh system is what we need to
stop pandemics
now often in movies we'll have pandemics
and I'm always impressed with what takes
place let's look at an example of this
rapid response
[Music]
well that's quite impressive we don't
need the music but otherwise we saw
exactly what should happen an outbreaks
detected very quickly literally within
days doctors are dispatched they have a
helicopter to get into exactly Ground
Zero they go in there and they they've
got the right tools and this is what
should happen when an outbreak is
spotted
but we don't have that team we don't
have those resources and if if an
outbreak took place in a low-income
country it could be literally months
before we started to orchestrate those
resources
so despite what you see in movies there
is no group of experts standing by to
prevent This Disaster
so we have to create a new team I
believe we should create what I call the
germ team germ stands for
Global epidemic response and
mobilization
this group is full-time their only
priority is pandemic prevention
it's made up of a diverse set of
Specialists with a lot of different
Realms of expertise epidemiologists data
scientists Logistics experts and it's
not just scientific and medical
knowledge they also have to have
communication and diplomacy skills
the cost of this team is significant
it's over a billion a year to support
the 3 000 people who would be on this
team and its mission is to stop
outbreaks before they become pandemics
the work would be coordinated by The Who
they'd be present in many locations
around the world stationed in public
health agencies they'd work closely with
the national teams depending on the
income level you know they'd have more
in the lower income countries you know
for example we could have germ members
say an epidemiologist working out of the
Africa CDC office in Abuja and a very
important thing is that like
firefighters
uh germ team would do drills when you
want to have quick response when you
want to make sure you have all the
pieces there and you can move very
quickly practice is key that's how you
make sure everyone knows what to do
now this team there could be periods
where there's no risky outbreak and they
can keep their skills strong
by working on some of the other
infectious diseases but that would be a
a second priority
they would work with countries to
strengthen their health systems
the health systems are
the front line
you need to know if say a lot of people
show up with a a new kind of cough
that's when germ needs to look into it
and say is this an outbreak is there a
new pathogen here what is the sequence
of that and so for all of this the first
100 days are key viruses spread
exponentially and so if you get in there
when the infection rate is fairly small
you can actually stop the spread you
know in this epidemic if we've been able
to stop it within 100 days we would have
saved over 98 of the lives now we did
have countries that did a good job
Australia is an example they
orchestrated diagnostic capacity they
came up with distancing policies and
quarantine policies and so their overall
death rate per capita will be well less
than a tenth of other countries but we
did not as a world uh contain it and
that's what we have to do next time
when covet struck we were almost like
Rome before they had fire buckets and
firefighters we didn't have the people
the systems or the tools we need now
with the right Investments we can have a
whole new generation of tools better
Diagnostics Therapeutics and vaccines a
good example uh in the diagnostic area
is this little machine this is called
the lumira we can have these all over
the world to contest for any number of
diseases it's a tent as expensive as PCR
it's absolutely is accurate and it's
simple so it can be used anywhere we
need other r d Investments one that I'm
very excited about it's the idea of a
drug that you inhale that blocks you
from getting infected can be pathogen
independent and Trigger immune system so
that you'll be protected
a lot of the tools the diagnostic tools
and those infection blocking tools are
important because they can be staged in
advance
now we also need vaccines but we want to
stop the outbreak before we have to do a
global vaccination campaign and so
vaccines can play a couple of different
roles but not the primary role we have
to invest in more than just that
when we look at vaccines they were the
miracle of this epidemic they saved
millions of lives but they can be far
better
we need to invent easier to deliver
vaccines that are just a patch you put
on your arm or something that you inhale
we need vaccines that actually block
infections in this case there were lots
of breakthrough infections we need
vaccines that are broad spectrum so they
work against most of the emerging
variants which we did not have this time
and we also need factories that are
standing by so we can build enough
vaccines for the entire world within six
months and Achieve far better equity
the vaccines can also do something uh
that would be super helpful which is to
help us eradicate entire families of
viruses Innovative new vaccines used
properly could get rid of the flu family
the coronavirus family and there's a
huge burden of those even in
non-pandemic years and if we get rid of
it it can never cause a pandemic so I'm
talking about investments in three broad
areas disease monitoring that's germ the
r d tools that are far better and
finally and the most expensive is
improved Health Systems this won't be
cheap but it'll save lives and even
it'll save money in the long run it's uh
like an insurance policy
the cost to prevent the next pandemic
will be tens of billions of dollars but
let's compare that to what we just went
through uh the IMF estimates that covid
has cost nearly 14 trillion dollars and
so we need to spend billions in order to
save trillions
and here's the best part of this even
when we're not having an outbreak these
Investments like the lemura those new
vaccines
they will make people healthier they'll
shrink the Gap the Health Equity gap
which is gigantic between rich and poor
countries
for example uh we can detect more HIV
cases and and do a better job of
treatment we can reduce deaths from
malaria we can get more people high
quality care and so this is not just a
downer about how to stop things from
getting worse but also a chance to make
things better
if we take the right steps we can make
covid-19 the last pandemic and we can
build a healthier more Equitable world
for everyone
thank you
thank you thank you thank you so much
um I have a few follow-up questions and
one is really about the formal status of
gem so you mentioned this would cost a
billion dollars you mentioned it comes
through the who but exactly like who's
running this how does this work how do
we make this happen
uh well germ does not exist it's a
proposal I'm putting forward that
hopefully over the next year while the
pain of the pandemic is still clear in
people's minds will get a global
consensus the rich World governments
will have to step up like they do uh
with all laid things and come up with
that money uh the way the Personnel
systems works so that it's under who but
a really top-notch team there'll be a
lot of debate about how to do that well
so you know I'm putting it forward and
uh hopefully within the next year we'll
get that consensus who do you need to
pick that up next well it's really the
rich World governments um you know who
has this big yearly meeting the World
Health assembly and at some point
somebody will put forward a resolution
and we'll see uh if the the extra
resources can be put in for that if it's
you know after World War II we did a lot
you know we created the United Nations
we talked a lot about wars so I'd be
stunned and although you know so far the
action has been less than I would have
expected I'd be stunned if we don't go
forward with something pretty close to
to what I'm uh laying out there
this has been pretty personal for you
you have you know the anti-vaxxers are
out there they are loud and this has
become personal I just wanted to ask
like how are you how are you managing
that
well it's kind of weird uh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
now our our foundation The Gates
Foundation is very involved in vaccines
the invention of new vaccines funding
vaccines and we're very proud that uh
through joint efforts like Gabi uh that
saved tens of millions of lives so it's
somewhat ironic to have somebody turn
around and say no you know we're using
vaccines to kill people or to make money
or you know we started the pandemic even
some strange things like that I somehow
on a track you know the location of
individuals because I'm so deeply
desirous to know where everybody is uh
I'm not sure what I'm going to do with
that information and
you know does this turn into something
where you know there's constantly crazy
people showing up who knows uh but you
know hopefully as the pandemic calms
down people are more rational about hey
vaccines are a miracle and there's a lot
more we can do
so the future is in our hands in the
present
Bill Gates thank you so much for being
here thank you